an MP assaulted me it's quite early on
in my career and I was quite quite young
lissa Whittaker worked in Parliament for
two decades where she suffered low-level
harassment and bullying before being
assaulted and stalked by an MP
I've actually really struggled late
lately with the idea that I had sort
devoted nearly 20 years of my life to an
organisation that failed me they failed
in their duty of care to look after me
and I find that really upsetting because
I didn't deserve that I I deserve to be
treated fairly and that's why I really
wanna stand up stand up and say this
today because there were still people
that aren't being treated fairly a new
report out today shines a light on how
common this type of experience is it
heard examples of unwelcome sexual
advances describing breasts being
grabbed and crotches being pressed and
rubbed against bodies it also found that
some of the worst offenders are well
known within Parliament but despite this
there's a general disregard for the
dignity well-being and rights of MP
staff a lot of the behavior I saw is
behavior that could have been nipped in
the bud it really quite an early stage
if there was some form of structure in
place so in in a relationship where
there's an enormous power imbalance
staff felt too frightened to ask the MP
for clearer guidance on how to do a
particular piece of work or to raise any
concerns one of the biggest problems
identified by this report is the culture
here in Parliament the blurred lines
between the professional and the
personal with overnight work trips and
late-night dinners the power dynamics of
a boss who overstepped the mark but
holds the power over your career in
their hands and of course as the
politics parliament is a unique and
difficult place to police but this
report concludes that that excuse is no
longer good enough the culture has to
change but things aren't changing fast
enough for some a vote in Parliament
next week could if it passes as
government sources expect extend the
complaints process to include historic
allegations which would be a big step
forward but concerns remain it's still
corrosive it's still there and you know
the the bullying has not lessened and
was seen from some
the cases of sexual harassment that they
continue apace the people and misusing
power so with those who understand the
problems recommend a friend working
Westminster I still think it's a great
place to work could be a great place to
work change is happening here but it's
been too slow for many that just 34 of
650 MPs signed up for recent voluntary
training on the issue shows us still a
long way to go Kate McCann Sky News